good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast welcome back on sir
good morning Millennials it's hot it's
[ __ ] balls in New York it's hot as
balls you are such a regular on the show
I mean because you work here now that we
don't even do snitch on the toast
hey snitch on the toast but I think it's
so important that we do it because it
really sets the mood that's true first
snitch on the toters snitch on the toes
it's just what this is that is what this
is oh wow i matter our future our I
guess it's been a while yeah Monday
since we sat here live we've been doing
podcasts all week they've all been very
different and very enjoyable because
Tuesday's episode was maybe the funniest
podcast episode ever
what oh you did oh I did i watch and I
was actually like I was not okay sorry I
forgot that was on Tuesday because I
sounded drunk I was not drunk but I
really sounded like it and here so there
was something going on with my
microphone and hearing the echo and
hearing myself in my headphones I
couldn't think and I could get worse out
[ __ ] funny like I was
I listened once we got to wherever we
were and I was just like listening on
the bed and I literally fell over I
could not breathe it was so funny no it
was so hilarious then Wednesday you
didn't episode with Claudia in the back
of an uber which might be first yeah
that was definitely first I mean I think
it was pretty good we were really just
chucking and drivin so which is your
favorite thing to do that's what she
said listen I didn't listen if you it's
fine I didn't listen either yesterday
but who is the caller from Kentucky
Claudia oh she called it sounded like
she called in oh we did something
different um and you got like Britney or
like sounds like we had a radio collar
sorry to disappoint yeah oh that's like
so late okay got it no I was uh named um
wow that's so crazy you should start a
podcast called like snitching cars yeah
can like instead of comedians in cars
getting coffee addiction cars talking
your ear off
probably on TNN podcasting in cars
inside cars make so much noise but you
guys have a pretty good but that's
because we weren't like if we do that in
the city it would be game over but this
there was like nothing around except for
greenery and mist
it was the ideal place I've heard a lot
about the vistas things were actually
super Mistah really yeah like II what I
loved it you could have been like more
than you were on the way to camp toast
she literally it was videoing everything
you would have just been like had your
phone up the whole time oh my god it was
I was very pleased by Kentucky by the
Kentucky business Howard the Minnesota
business Minnesota was very um urban
yeah but your holiday yeah there a lot
of high-rises like so I wasn't expecting
that so there's not that many vistas
like that because they were high-rises
walking said vistas he cube hit up the
Mall of America nope did you want to I
did until I saw a post in the toasters
today that anyone was targeted for human
trafficking involve America and
apparently it's a big human trafficking
target and I feel I was thinking what I
should share that yeah that seems
pertinent a woman was in the Mall of
America and someone who looks like work
there said the place is on lockdown you
have to come to the basement with us but
one of their friends was in the bathroom
so she was like we have to wait for my
friend
he was like who's your friend I guess I
got a bad vibe so they just like walked
away to go get her from the bathroom and
then just like left and went to their
car and then found out that it wasn't on
lockdown and then found out that it's
usually a target for sex trafficking so
if they had gone down to the basement
like it would have just been all over is
that how that works like we just take
you
I guess that's that's [ __ ]
frightening because there's someone's
always unlocked out of course I would go
in there the Mall of America I guess you
don't get his chad's about the Mall of
America because you were too young to
remember the mary-kate and Ashley
episode where they go to the Mall of
America and they ride the roller coaster
I might but I just like can't place it
you know yeah I've seen it was like I
mean there's five years between us and I
guess I experienced things and watch
things in those five years that that you
did it or no I probably watch them with
you but I was like not a human that it
didn't register yeah so anyways that's
why we love them all of America gave me
you know that episode PETA's easy a okay
it's a mary-kate and Ashley summer party
episode where they just like start
putting weird [ __ ] on the pizza like I
definitely have seen it but just like it
definitely doesn't roll off my tongue
because I was like I said not a human
what about brother for sale
yes that I know five cents you would do
it I would do that counselor for sale 25
cents tell my worth you're worth more it
was a different time that was worth that
was like a dollar bag Wow anyways we
have such a fun show for you guys
because obviously we're gonna deliver
the past five stories I'm gonna catch up
with the snitch rouhani was on last
night so I'll talk a bit about it even
though not nothing really happened
nothing of note you know it was just a
nice finale episode and watch what
happens live tenth anniversary we'll
talk a bit about that but yeah just I
haven't seen you since your travels and
I've missed you councilors missed you
too and you have the boy this weekend
well we're sharing the boy this we're
sharing the boy this weekend because
it's let's go NWO which if you're a new
toaster it means it's Nucky's weekend
out which means that he's staying with
his aunt HS it could be either aunt
because he's or or Olivia because he's a
nephew but this weekend it's with me
he's and I and the last time we had an
NWO Zack was on his bachelor party so I
did it all by myself and I didn't you
know I it was definitely stressful but
it was only my stress but you know it's
like I had the stress of NWO plus like
making sure that Theo doesn't piss off
Zack and so far it's been actually
really nice even nice to him he's been
nice to him so yesterday when Theo got
to my house like and Papa left he was
really upset and he was like looking for
him in the apartment for so long and I
was like dude he's not he's not coming
back
he's not coming back and so see it was
just being like super Shady honestly and
like he was like he wouldn't come up on
the couch she'd be just like stare at me
on the couch I would get it come on
and he wouldn't come to me the same
couch at home so it's like this should
be the one familiar thing anyways he
would like lay on the hardwood floor he
was reminding me of Lindsay Lohan and
Confessions of a Teenage Drama Queen he
was like boycott he was protein yeah
yeah he like wouldn't eat his dinner but
then obviously he he ate but then when
Zach came home he was like so excited he
got right on the kitchen she likes like
a male figure maybe maybe like a male
aura cuz he's a male
yes much as we don't want him to be I
know he was steadily seeking some
testosterone so he was in good spirits
when Zach came home and then we wound up
going to sleep and
he was able to sleep with us after you
know first sack was like he'll sleep in
the crate and I was like okay that's
fine because it is an easier night's
sleep
but then he hasn't slept in the crate in
so long he was just like didn't want to
be there and Zack was I find he could
sleep with us but then I wound up paying
the price because he took up my whole
side of the bed he sucked hard you have
to when he does that like you just have
to move him like he is so tired that he
will not like wake up from it like you
just take him scoop him and put him
where you want I just didn't want to
disturb him I know
by the way Papa is Ben and I call him
Papa because I just feel like if tio
could speak he would say oh so you're
saying oh you're saying that when Ben
left when I left I thought it was just a
cup that's why I said the whole mail or
thing Oh obviously because he's
oppressed that his dad left no I know
but I said I call him papa okay well you
transition from Zach to Papa slash Ben
not really sorry I just I expect you all
to know what's going on in my head and
it's complicated up there it's
complicated stuff anyways and OBO is
going great Theo is home right now and
you'll be helping me throughout the
weekend because we woke up at 6:00 a.m.
and that can't happen again that can
happen to me either
it won't for you it's just different it
didn't happen when I was on my own
okay but is like anyways anyways are you
ready I'm so ready it's time I'm it's
time it's always time it's always time
to hit you with the fast side stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast I don't have to make this on
manual anymore but before we get into
that I just want to let you know that
today's episode is sponsored by
Squarespace Squarespace is an amazing
place to create a beautiful website you
can turn your cool idea into a new
website you can showcase your work blog
or publish content sell products and
services of all kinds promote your
physical or online business you can say
more and sell more stand out in any
inbox with now Squarespace email
campaigns they're all in one platform
makes it easy to unify your brand voice
from your homepage to your emails keep
it consistent from website to email they
have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers powerful ecommerce
functionality which lets you sell
anything online and everything is
optimized for mobile right out of the
box so if you have an idea for a
business or you want to just get your
voice heard write a blog you know show
take any of your various talents we
recommend Squarespace and head to
squarespace.com sasha toast for a free
trial when you're ready to launch your
site use the offer code toast to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain so that squarespace.com /
toasts use offer code toast to save 10%
off your website or domain exciting
times - make website maybe you should
make a website speaking of you did a Q&A
and I have to admit like you are
becoming quickly like my favorite
influencer Wow yang I just love when
you're doing influencer stuff obviously
like I love calling you you're my sister
but like when you do q and A's when you
do ads I'm just like that money at that
money saving add the others like tell me
more counsellor snitch it's because your
accounts are like you're just like and
we're all your campers right we're not
your followers yes so you did a Q&A
where someone asked of you whatever
starting YouTube channel and you were
like I don't know what should I and I
was like yeah
yeah I've thought about it but it's such
a scary world like I don't know if I
could handle it I think you could handle
like this scare ninis of it
I just think it's a lot of work new yeah
but it also likes a while before it
becomes rewarding yeah and it's like
then like when you launch it's like oh
my god like I know subscribers are like
just like the mean comments people are
so people you think people are mean on
Instagram like they're [ __ ] ruthless
on on YouTube so like my anxiety is
already bad like I don't know that I
need to make it even worse
I feel that and it's like what would be
the point like you what would you do
there that you can't do an instant right
like yeah so I don't know I mean it
would be like interesting I don't know
it's something just to think about it
somebody think about yeah I'll play with
it for a little bit in my head and see
what I come come with yeah like I would
love like vlog a day in the life so
that's like a one video you had that's
one video yeah yeah so it just I'm like
you know who what's her name
Danielle Carolyn yeah she puts out
content like it's nobody's business
there was a time when she did one a day
whoa
and I was just like how hey like how was
your life interesting enough to do
something every single day and B how do
you get it up I know she came on the
show so she is a comic and you know
what's so interesting is that when I was
doing the morning toast members
main group so many of the answers of how
they heard about us was from her that's
crazy
yeah she's got to come back yeah she's a
great gal anyways something to think
about for you just if you want to
continue influencing which I really
think you haven't asked for I'm a fully
influenced influence where my fabletics
you actually they're so good you really
should get them maybe night no totally
anyways let's get into the past five
stories because they're they're decent
today first up we have Khloe
Kardashian's 35th birthday party and
just yesterday was Khloe's 35th birthday
and I was catching up on her and scrap
stories and like so many people love her
you know so many people so many people
just want the best for her her family
made like a video montage well wishing
her but like II put it together I didn't
understand that I didn't I honestly
didn't really see it okay well it was
really sweet everyone's just talking
about how much they loved her and like
how they want the best for her and how
they're like so excited to celebrate
with her it was just like really I think
everyone just like wants it to work for
her do you I mean and it's like everyone
was saying like this is gonna be your
best year yet she had a party that Kylie
I guess threw for her at Kylie's house
and it was just like kind of backyard
vibes like it wasn't anything crazy was
beautiful and pink and like floral and
she had this super cool photo booth that
was like a fake pink gym and like you
get in like you pose but everything's so
cute didn't I see that the pictures
aren't up yet but we haven't seen any
pictures we just saw that she had that
photo booth and it just really looks
like a very like teeny affair it when
they do those all pink parties like
those are the steamiest of affairs like
her baby shower was so freakin steamy it
was so cute Kylie skin launched oh that
- yeah that one looks and also there was
a lot of branding for the Kylie Khloe
collab so I think it wasn't right off of
a party they definitely wrote it off so
good for you guys because like it's one
thing to be like beautiful and smart and
rich and it's another thing to get
around taxes truly to be business savvy
totally so just yeah I can't believe I
don't know I just I really feel like I
never ride the stir celebrities
birthdays but like Chloe's 35th like
really hit home for me and it seemed
like it did for a lot of other people
but what I do have say is at the
Kardashians
respect the hell out of birthdays that's
true like they always have a birthday
party and like it's like a banger of a
birthday party like it's not just it's
cuz I feel like they don't really party
that much or drink really so when
someone L was passing around shots and
in her video she was like I love just
getting drunk with you and yelling at
each other like I feel like it's rare so
when it's a birthday they're like oh
like this is that one time a month or
whatever yeah and so then they just like
go to town and like that I I'm here for
that and I like would just love the fact
I family through maybe like worth it
like that
okay well maybe next year I yeah
birthday parties are so tough also for
us it's like we really hang out with
like 15 people yeah and how many parties
are we gonna throw for the same 15
people it's roughly just GNO just a
little bit extended right now it's like
you don't want to do it you don't wanna
do a Gino dinner because like there's
nothing worse than a group dinner right
it's not Gianna right um but it's like
you can't like have a party like we
don't have enough and we could invite
more people in fill the room do you have
to see those people exactly but I feel
like the Kardashians must have that
issue too because they really only hang
out to select few people as well yeah so
I don't know yeah they definitely have
the same problem so it's it's
interesting but and they also always
have a venue which is easy yeah that is
their homes that's true for Claude's
birthday we're going to Vegas which is a
great way which is a great way to stay
get all of your money on flights right
and a great way to get your favorite 15
people together truly truly I'm so
excited I'm really excited did I gotta
get in shape my guys I got um some stuff
from forever 21 that came yesterday it
was pretty cute but we'll see I ordered
um I just like I don't know you know
targeted ads are just getting me these
days and I saw like you know like the
classic like pink latex that like Kylie
where war am revolve $68 super down oh
my god I always get targeted for that
dress and I always click on in and sold
out but I got it okay that's another
amazing yeah so that should be exciting
that's exciting
yeah I'm excited I'm excited for that
but aside from that ya know I gotta get
in shape and I gotta just get clothing
the hardest part is the cute day outfit
I feel like a night dress you figure it
out but the cute day outfit that's the
kicker I know like to be an amazing suit
and like but no Society in an outfit
yeah like it's not just the
bathing suit is like what do you put
over it that's a cute enough yes it's
truly the hardest thing ever it's across
the bay I don't know how they live in
siesta key oh yeah you should just shop
there like to know it's air whatever
that's true like text really a porter I
was like hey where do you shop and do
they have 800 size Baker crazy [ __ ] is
going down in the key but I don't even
know because I don't have MTV so I don't
know where we were at and where and like
I never finished the last season but as
far as I know like it ended with like um
I'm pretty sure Alex and Juliet were
together and then she was with Robbie
she's no longer with Robbie right all I
know is like from Instagram I guess and
from the toasters to then a toaster said
that like Kara is back home in New
Jersey like her show her story lying
pretty much fizzle out okay I thought
she thought she's like really pretty but
like she bothered me Kelsey and Juliet
are the best of friends and like they're
not friends with Chloe but now they're
friends with Chloe which means like they
were in a fight and they probably just
made up and it's like I just I so
annoying like what I like is that they
show it all kind of like on their story
and it's like while they're filming like
they don't go dark you know but then
it's like I've so many freaking
questions and I want to know there's so
much to keep up with like it many no you
have two best friends
Chloe and out yeah I just it's too much
honestly I think I'm like too old to
like yeah keep up with all that it
requires watching your stories
everything every single day because
something changes every day every day
craziness okay next up speaking a more
relationship drama have you heard about
Lala and Carmelo Anthony yes I have Lala
Anthony is quote a wreck after Carmelo
caught yachting with mystery gal okay
I don't know what to make of this story
I mean there's anything there there
Mahwah Anthony is a wreck after photos
circulated of her husband Carmelo on a
yacht with another woman and bloggers
theorized he might be cheating the
former NIC star has vehemently denied
any hanky-panky
but quote she's a wreck over it a source
told page six on Thursday morning Lala
posted then deleted a photo of a bloody
heart with a dagger in it on Instagram
oh that's like clear as day
hello tried to clear up any drama in a
video obtained by TMZ in which he
explains the woman in the photo is
married all them bloggers that's trying
to put that out there that [ __ ] is not
cool that's not cool at all the only
reason I'm addressing this is because
this is affecting my family now and you
got me out here looking crazy usually I
won't address this but I had to address
this another insider confirmed that the
couple who separated in 20
17 and reconciled the next year are
still together but a different source
told us that la la' is currently in
therapy okay I have scared that no one
knows what's good I also read that
Carmela said that the husband my wife
was on the yacht so what's the problem
ya know him just saying that she's
married like married women can she - but
the husband of the wife being on the I
okay so was a group trip but why wasn't
la la' there and it was her birthday and
it was her birthday
that's weird in and of itself like
that's why la la' should be bad but he
wasn't around for her birthday
there's definitely something fishy going
on in their relationship but it's not
this woman I agree and also like if he
was cheating you really think he'd do it
like that just like out on a boat like
knowing full well that pop perhaps will
get you like if you're in the middle of
the boat in the middle of the sea it's
like where else do you have more privacy
I guess but you don't because how many
times have you seen that photo yeah of
someone on me we were like just too
close to port yeah for sure
I don't know like date I feel like they
stay together for the sake of their kids
and like I feel like la la has just like
one foot in and one foot out this
definitely it's definitely their own
sort of really relationship but I really
like them together and each I just don't
want him to be like upsetting her same
so it's like what you need to do and men
just get their [ __ ] together right like
it's [ __ ] time and just whatever is
going on like spend your wife's birthday
with her it's like I could achieve me on
the know it's also like literally the
least you sounds like it was a couples
trip yeah if the woman that you're with
and her husband are there why isn't your
wife right so that just like does not
bode well yes but I don't think he was
cheating on her in this particular
instance me neither
maybe like the day before but not not
that day right like maybe he went below
deck and she's really not in not in that
photo was he cheating yeah I happened to
be like laying next to someone next to a
woman I agree
speaking of lying next to me I'm caught
up on song land I talked about it with
Claudia on the podcast yesterday right
yeah oh I didn't I just don't like her
computer and I wasn't gonna watch it and
then Zack was like you should watch it
because it's the real pop episode you
know okay okay it's pop music okay um
and she she was really good she really
is a songwriter that's true at heart so
she's actually kind of funny and like
she just has a cool personality
okay she's really
like knows who she is and she doesn't
take herself too seriously I'll watch it
I don't like I just I enjoy watching the
show so much it really like doesn't
actually matter who the artist is it's
such a great show
I obviously looked into like whether or
not it's doing well it looks like it's
like at the top of the charts or
whatever but if you're not watching it
you should have hundred percent be
watching and it's just like interesting
it's really talented people and I love
that at the end of the day what they're
doing the prize that you win is like
sets you up for life you know if you
have a hit song like a real number one
like it's a house song like will.i.am
said it can buy you a house my own fear
my only fear about it that was like it's
like I just feel like I feel like in TV
we're like they're taking it seriously
but in the music world they're not
really taking it seriously like none of
the songs that have been released have
really like been a hit yet well okay I
want to say and I don't think that some
music I don't think that's anyone's
fault other than I love the show I like
a lot of the songs but there has yet to
be one song that I've heard that I'm
like I need to string this right now I'm
obsessed with this song I'm gonna list
it over and over again some of the songs
I'm like I want to hear what it came out
I know what I've been liking though is
like the songs that don't win like that
song me from the Jonas Brothers when
Ryan Tedder brought in the choir
I have not stopped listening to what
what do you think of me or whatever is
that on it's yeah the girl sings it they
like the song yeah and it's so [ __ ]
good at the fact like I wanted Ryan
Tedder to take that song and make it a
one or public song when the Jonas
Brothers hitting people there are so
many songs that are getting left behind
and they're not like the greatest songs
ever but like someone should pick them
up like agree if I were an artist I
would watch the show and be like hey the
the Meghan Trainor one there was like a
really catchy when it's only when I've
still had stuck in my head and they
changed so much of it but I have the
original one which is a we don't got no
money but we're right but like she has
money now so she couldn't sing that and
someone should pick that yeah but you
know which one has been stuck in my head
like and it was like the second episode
the way I am be different be nice like
that was I that's a [ __ ] Bob okay
well I am episode impressed me so much I
thought like he just like
farted around on an exile ofone I had no
idea he was like so talented um but I
love the boxes song me too and Zach me
the best call he was like that should
Ben this song for Toy Story for cuz like
we're no longer in boxes oh that's cute
thankee yeah but um you know what I
thought I thought that like I knew
Kelsea Ballerini had talent because I
knew she started as a songwriter it's
got nothing in that episode was shocking
Jonas Brothers I have to say truly
shocked me and I will say that Nick
Jonas really shocked me he is so
talented
like I'm not he sit I still don't like
him but he just like he like just hears
things in his head and then just like
put it out in them and like the notes
and the keyboard and the but like I was
so impressed that's what I learned from
chasing happiness or I mean I watched it
yeah and I knew then that's when I
learned oh wow these guys are like
actually musicians especially me me too
but like I just had come to like Elton
John gift yeah Rocket Man we're seeing
it come to life was like truly shocking
like I was four minutes in and I like
saw like what what this episode was
becoming and I like called Claudie I was
like you have to watch the Jonas
Brothers on song line right now cuz like
it's shocking and I was truly shocked
yeah Zach made us watch it like we went
on a border but you know like I does not
please me yeah it doesn't really matter
it doesn't matter whatever like they
never allude back to previous episodes
and I love the three I love Shane
McNally I love ester dean and I [ __ ]
love Ryan Tedder I don't know which one
I love the most meaning I love them all
so much
like when I think it's ester but I'm
like but chain but Ryan right can I know
I like it's a masterpiece of a show and
I hope that like it doesn't become like
they're switching in and out like not
judges but producers because I really
really really like these three yeah and
they're honestly the only three that I
actually know even prior to the show I
didn't know Shane I did because he looks
so familiar because he won all the
Grammys with Kacey Musgraves he was on
stage a single time yes maybe that's why
he just looks so familiar that's why she
always thinks Shane McAnally you've
heard her say she and McNally a hundred
times no I his face is what's familiar
because he's always standing behind her
okay
okay fine anyways third story is a
little bit of a throwback and I'm
curious if you were alive because
Christy Carlson hermano
you know that is leans into Disney past
for a new cooking show on the heels of
her incredibly personal Teen Vogue
saying which she revealed her past
Ruggles with drinking and depression
Christy Carlson Romano is getting back
to her light-hearted side with her new
cooking series Christie's kitchen
throwback quote the purpose of that
article was to be open and show people a
different side of me and I think I did
that
she told page six on Thursday following
the release of her first episode in
which he and former Kim Possible co-star
Wilf Riedel recreate the show's famous
nacho taco aka the NACO oh my god the
web series has a purposefully upbeat
tone and as the 35 year old mother of
two described it quote I've been ready
to explore how I embrace my past but
also do something fun it's still
valuable to fans the things I've done in
the past I'm not one of those people
who's going to completely didn't know
who's going to be completely denying the
nostalgic factor of even Stevens our Kim
Possible at work cadet Kelly or anything
I was associated with so why not lean
into it why not enjoy the fact that I
have people who really like to talk
about it and want to celebrate it so I
think this is this show is a celebration
of a nostalgia wow this is so in tune
and so it doesn't say so in tune and
whenever for some reason I think of Kim
Possible yes I think of the show but the
games that they had on Disney Channel's
calm for Kim Possible specifically I
played like it was my job they had the
snowboarding game and also like the taco
game in the restaurant I played it
literally like you don't even know and
the cadet Kelly games too that they
haven't dizzy times like um I wonder if
they're ever gonna bring those back I
think they're in in our camp archive
it's like literally what I grew up doing
like [ __ ] fortnight Disney Channel comm
ya know for us it was what's an
icebreaker what's the one I see tower
I see tower I still play that I used to
I played that and I'm in NYU last
semester i rake your space bar it's time
for I see time break your sand when he
made it to light up oh [ __ ] and also um
what was the other one called
Oh like mini clip remember aqua
energizer dad yeah yeah I think that one
related to that was the one yeah and
then of course then we elevated to
things like brick breaker you know we
were real sophisticated yes burger was
great yes I said the iPhone like doesn't
have a game I wish that we were still
using
blackberries as opposed to iPhones
[ __ ] bbm that was lit changing your
status yeah don't know supermarket like
every time you did anything go it is no
not me but like any
anyone did anything it's like if you're
going to your friend's house it's like
you making your status
yeah good times man good times man and
it's all about like how many friends you
have yeah but soon will be like talking
about those days like about Instagram
like remember he's supposed to our story
when we were like using a filter
I long for those days no totally anyways
I'm happy for Chrissy cross hermano
there's nothing I hate more than when
celebrities deny the thing that made
them who they are and pretend like you
know there's something that they're not
so this is unbelievably in tune
I don't watch cooking shows but if I did
I would watch this and it's a web series
which just sounds like a great starting
point for her to have a show like on
Food Network yeah yeah yeah I agree
like if it goes well why not and and
also I'm pretty sure she was involved in
the kimba Hospital remake I might have
made that up but it seems like that
would make sense I don't know I was
boycotting the remake I know she's
getting that girl like seems really cute
yeah and like she's she said I haven't
seen her anywhere else like I don't even
know what anything I hasn't even come
out yeah it's already on the Disney
Channel app oh that app is out now no
the Disney streaming app is like a
behemoth of an app that's coming out but
they have like Disney Channel Oh like
the CW app right where you can watch
like a handful of d coms and like some
behind the scenes stuff about
descendants yeah thank you sentence is
coming out too I know and we're having a
watch part we have to watch oh we have
to watch the first two prior and then
yeah and we'll have the O with us and
it'll be I'm actually very very jazz I
have much any trailers for it cuz I
don't like watching trailers it gives
away the plot yeah um Theo has never
seen descendants so that's gonna be
really exciting for him my god he's
gonna love it she's gonna love it
I know Wow okay next story because Joe
Jonas and sophie Turner are you okay
sorry
just was [ __ ] out I almost said
Sophia like let's pray for me Joe Jonas
and sophie turner throw a pre-ceremony
pool party at their wedding chateau in
France okay well this is just a great
story because they're getting married
and they're throwing a pool party and
isn't that fun it's more important that
they are staying at the Chateau that the
women of Real Housewives of
Hills just stayed at last week on Bravo
do you think that she's a Beverly Hills
fan you know what I could see her being
mean to no person but I feel like we
would know if she was like she would
talk about it um yeah whenever she goes
on like those shows
so I mean she's never gonna watch what
happens I'd she's done a lot she does a
lot of press she literally just got off
the biggest press tour of all time for
Game of Thrones finale and x-men yeah so
she wasn't gonna do it then then it was
said she's not a fan so I have to
believe that she is not a fan which is
fine I mean record-breaking temperature
highs in France in other parts of
Western Europe the couple kept cool by
the pool alongside family and friends
Thursday at their wedding venue the
beautiful chateau de Toro Turner and her
husband were spotted spending time with
the groom's brothers Nick and Kevin plus
their wives Priyanka and Danielle Jonas
just like the korsak's I love them so
much me too
I've seen a photo share by E news many
of the gatherings participants carry
drinks while in lounging by the estate's
grande pool okay so like here's one
photo she just looks so [ __ ]
beautiful I love her so so much and like
I want them to stay this relevant
forever do you know what I mean you know
but I have so many thoughts first of all
though it's not every day that you hear
the word wedding and pool party in the
same sentence no there's they're so
[ __ ] cool they're just so cool I'm
sure it was like not planned it was so
hot and no one wanted to do anything
other than swim and they were like we
have this dope pool come through yeah
but I hope they stay relevant forever
which I will because people will always
be interested in them but like no one
will ever be as relevant or busy as joe
jonas and sophie turner have been in the
last two months and it's like i no
longer want to hear people who broke up
because of scheduling issues because if
joe jonas can come back with the jonas
brothers while sophie Turner is
promoting Game of Thrones finale and
x-men and in that same time they get
married and also plan a wedding and have
another wedding and have never seen
better and it also goes together there's
no excuse for anyone else I could not
agree more yeah if you really love
someone you [ __ ] figure it out she
went to the x-men premiere in LA and
then
next day was at was with Joe for the
album lon yeah if they can figure it out
so can you
I agree I agree wholeheartedly but with
their bullets like now because of these
two it shouldn't be acceptable for that
masseuse for her publicist to put out
that statement like a news source to
write back and be like what about Joe so
yeah Joe and Sophie yeah like don't tell
me that guys still have love for each
other right that's horseshit like I will
no longer be accepting I wasn't
accepting it before but now I'm really
gonna put my foot down and like anyone
who comes back with like scheduling
conflict as a reason why their
relationship didn't work out I'm just
gonna assume the absolute worst yeah
and I just saw actually that Maisie
Williams just landed in France for the
wedding and I'm just like and I'm just
so excited to see the content that comes
out of it like I'm sure like I feel like
sophie was like universally well liked
on the set of Game of Thrones so I feel
like literally everyone will be there
and it's like I'm just I'm just so
excited and zoe kravitz you know Jason
Momoa stepdaughters also getting married
this weekend in the same town in France
and Provence I think the only overlap
there is Jason Momoa
and so I guess he has to go to his
stepdaughters wedding but I feel like he
should come through maybe how
comfortably an after party what is it
about this weekend like literally
everyone's getting married well it's a
it's a beautiful summer weekend I guess
so what is about this like small town in
France it's it's actually really cool
incidental that there's like two huge
celebrity weddings of this small town in
France and one of them is at the Chateau
that Beverly Hills housewives are just I
wonder if this world is want to book it
the world is massive but it's so small I
know totally I couldn't agree more
I heard this is a town that French
campers from yeah she's doing one of the
weddings I just can't tell you what yet
oh yeah but she was invited to both cuz
she's a good time she's a good best time
she's a life of a party she's like for
the party I think she's gonna go to Joe
and Sophie you like that no Herve a
party is going to be so fun like hmm I
just wish yeah we can Britax are getting
there I know and then I think maybe Erin
Foster I mean with katharine McPhee is
getting married today ' yeah because
she's speaking I was seeing some
Bachelorette vibe yeah or maybe it's
just about to our party but it could be
this weekend - I don't know and then
it's four that's crazy
yeah I'm like four key couple yeah key
key ok fifth and final story is
definitely a weird choice for the
morning toes it's definitely some biz
news have a minute no you definitely
haven't and I just found it to be like a
really sad headline stop American corn
farmers are having their worst year in
recent history America's corn soy and
wheat farmers are having a terrible year
so heavy rains and floods across the
growing regions have destroyed crops and
farmers have missed planting windows
last year's wet summer and snowy winter
along with this year's to late spring
and heavy rains have ruined business for
American grain farmers may 2018 through
April 2019 was the wettest 12-month
period on record for the United States
according to the US Department of
Agriculture who knew who knew since the
start of April America's Corn Belt has
faced record precipitation according to
Joe was Nicki meteorologists and
operational forecaster at commodity
weather group you know I love saying
random people's names yes so and you
know when you guys spoke about that
Netflix guy about the office yes and you
said like yeah I saw something posted it
was rad yeah so if any of you know Joe
wasn't it he was that hey Jim you the
recent rainfall and floods have given
driven grain futures to multi-year highs
over the past several weeks on June 17th
corn futures hit their highest level in
five years for the year they're up more
than seventeen percent which puts
futures on track for the steepest annual
price increase since 2010 so get your
corn now it's not just like so sad it's
really sad but who Orin is on its way
out oh my god that would be that would
be it's so sad they met everything that
corns in tortillas corn tortillas
regular corn popcorn ha I didn't even
think about popcorn yeah corn is
important you guys and you know what I
was thinking about yesterday as I was
eating a cow a flower flatbread
flatbread is that really like I wish I
could have invested in cauliflower in
cauliflower and like before that kale
like before that avocado and I was
thinking like what do you want can you
invest in a vegetable no you can invest
in a company that produces yeah that's
yeah like avocados from Mexico
one two what do you think it's the next
big adventure oh I don't know I thought
you would be a good person I know I
brought up this corn story also justice
for
corn farmers because it's like there's
nothing worse than the weather ruining
things for you yes like there's
literally nothing you can do about it
right what's the next veggie I was
thinking it has to be something that you
can like make a lot of things with and I
do so you could do a lot with brussel
sprouts
mmm I was thinking maybe like squash oh
but squash is always cool
yeah like delicious that's true or it's
like something that you can like
literally make into like calls are like
they literally make it into like a
[ __ ] pizza like yep uh I don't know I
don't know maybe like broccoli I think
actually maybe broccoli I feel like I've
seen like people making bigs out of
broccoli but broccolis has such a
dislike the great thing about
cauliflower is that tastes like nothing
it tastes like whatever you put on it
it's like I said was an interesting
factoid people are saying celery Oh
but like what else aside from celery
juice yeah celery is like too watery
just dissolve the protein cucumber
zucchini but zucchinis always been cool
zucchini has always been cool some new
ancient great eggplant eggplant always
been cool eggplant parm butternut squash
always been cool these are like sugary
delicious vegetable yeah like
cauliflower it was like one that's like
a game-changer yeah like maybe like hey
cup chick peas chickpeas are always
chickpea and they're kind of like
they've leveled out yeah
hummus we're good yeah yeah cauliflower
tastes like feet I actually always loved
Kali I've always I've called mostly
growing up like with I can't believe it
diverse right and eat like a whole
cauliflower and like slice it like a
cake
we were just free yeah you think it was
delicious yeah so this it wasn't shocked
to me that now I'm eating cauliflower
flatbreads no yeah it's not talk to me
at all and I'm very grateful for the
industry coming to life because it's
just honestly game-changing it really is
yeah it really is like whoever invented
the cauliflower pizza thank you next
thank you ness okay those are the past
five stories I told you they were decent
but you know you could have lived gotta
live without them but you couldn't have
lived without the toast this morning
because who would send you off for a
wonderful weekend but I want to talk
about Real Housewives of New York okay
and maybe I'll touch on The Bachelor
because everybody has been asking me to
okay you
what I would let you do that okay go for
it okay well the thing is is that I've
been watching and I haven't been posting
anything on my stories because every
single time that I do somebody replies
with the spoiler and I'm determined I'm
not even gonna look at the comments okay
I'm determined to not get it spoiled for
once not because they so care about and
she ends up with I just want to be
surprised and you ever see if you can
figure it out I mean why is that so hard
and so I know nothing I know no spoilers
and I really can say that I've
absolutely no idea who's gonna win
there's no clear front-runner at all I
really like how to be the whole loop
peace situation I'm not understanding
like usually producers make you keep the
villain around for a while but it's
gotten a little out of control and I
think she literally said basically she
has this guy who's actually a [ __ ]
psychopath and everyone is like there's
nine people left and she keeps keeping
him around and like he's making all
these problems and she said at the end
of this week's episode cuz even Chris
Harrison was like why is he still here
and she was like either unthought I'm in
love with him or he's making me go crazy
and I felt that I get that cuz like you
know sometimes you can't mash your head
in your heart but like it's like dude
and then I'm pretty sure like all the
guys get mad at Hannah because they're
like I'm questioning your judgment if
you still have this guy here which like
honestly I'm questioning her judgment
too because it makes absolutely no sense
he's he's the one I hope you've seen
anything he's gotten like mad at her for
like making out with other guys like the
whole thing about like it becomes a
problem later on about like sex and
stuff that like he's mad that she's like
he's like your body is a temple like
blah blah like it's like very weird
about like the things that she does and
he's like judging her and then only okay
thing to say when like your mom says
right you know yeah he was like being a
dad like being like you're like doing
too many like say like cuz she went like
bungee jumping naked with someone which
was they weren't expecting she she was
just like we're going bungee jumping and
then like the tradition is to go naked
and so then like they have no other
choice and so they didn't no bra no bra
yeah and so he like what he got mad at
her like fly off yeah well she like I
don't think she has what we've got and
like they weren't flying and he got mad
at her and like it started a whole thing
so he's I don't know but my favorites
are Tyler C and Peter the pilot and
truly I have no idea who she's gonna end
up with because right now she looks like
she likes Jed but Jenn apparently
I don't know if you've seen had a
girlfriend she didn't a 90 minute
episode with reality Steve like he's a
sketchy as [ __ ] I'm like honestly I
don't even like him that much so I don't
even know who she's gonna win it who's
gonna win I don't know who she's gonna
pick I I used to think the Tyler seed
was a fuck-boy cuz he just looks like a
[ __ ] boy but he's honestly really like
showed me that he's just like so great
honestly he's like so [ __ ] hot like
and the people who pilot is [ __ ]
Delta pilot and is such a precious gem
and I was like okay great but I feel
like she doesn't even see what she has
in front of her do you know what I mean
it's really been a truly tumultuous
season my you enjoying I am I am there's
lots of drama and like she's like oh
he's just like anything I love about her
is like she [ __ ] doesn't give a [ __ ]
like she just like yells at these boys
like she like will go into their room
when they're fighting good what the [ __ ]
is going on like just like stop like
just everyone just stay in your own lane
and just like stop all the drama and she
doesn't she's not afraid to call people
out on their [ __ ] which I enjoy I just
like her judgment is I'm just like a
little confused within sometimes oh my
god yeah like I'm with it I'm with you
I'm following you and then she does like
the loopy [ __ ] and it's like at this
point I don't even think producers are
telling her to keep him which makes me
think that like I like what are you
doing
understood so if you were a betting
woman and you were placing a bet right
now who would you put your who would you
bet $50 on that they're gonna win then
we can look back on this episode I know
I like I actually really usually you
know by now when I talk about to be
hometowns like you know who the
front-runner is and I have no idea
cuz it's like I know who I want to win
but I don't know that she like sees what
I see
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I I'll say what I want okay I
think Peter should win and I think Tyler
should be the bachelor but I like I
don't confident that that's gonna happen
okay you know we're at hometowns now
it's the episode right before hometowns
on Monday so there's like six people
yeah okay so that's not that far but I
might I will Evan love and make-a-wish
justice for the corn farmers I might um
I have all the episode saved so maybe
before paradise I will watch everything
like in one day and that would be
enjoyable I actually think that you
should because there's really good guys
coming out of the season who will
probably be on paradise and they'll just
be nice to know their background and it
really is a really good enjoyable season
like I'm not lying I believe you know it
was just
with just my time and people have said
like even though it's a good season like
there's still a lot of next week this
week coming up okay on this specific
episode that I'll tell you specifically
to [ __ ] skip because there was an
episode of drama and then the next
episode was a recap called Tana tells
all and it's just Chris Harrison and in
the middle of the season Chris Harrison
and Hanna sitting like this literally in
the bachelor mansion just doing a recap
of the first six episodes for two hours
that was [ __ ] terrible so yeah you
can skip that one oh wow okay well what
are people saying in the comments today
agree with me I just don't weird I'm
scared though you don't want people are
saying Mike for bachelor some would love
Tyler to be the next Bachelor
Peter broke up with his girlfriend to be
on the show heard that that was false
yeah I heard that was unfounded
I don't know I just I think you can make
that statement like about a lot of
people just everything I need context
like were they engaged in like she's
like really did they just start dating
and then he got this opportunity is like
okay we're like it wasn't going nowhere
and he was like maybe I'll do this and
it worked out and timing whatever like I
just don't think that's always the
craziest thing yeah and um Mike for
bachelor yes but I liked how she better
but Mike is [ __ ] hilarious like he's
just like so real on the show like
anytime like someone says something
stupid he's like it's just like
sometimes people like just don't realize
that they're actually in the real world
too and so like they just like are like
so fake or whatever but anytime anyone
does anything he's just like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
like like he'll just always just be like
rolling his eyes and just be like this
is so [ __ ] dumb and I appreciate that
so it wouldn't be upset if he was about
sorry there but like I just I would love
a whole season of Tyler saying would you
go on for Tyler see um I was actually
thinking about this last night when I
was on the plane I was watching The
Bachelor and like I just don't think I
could do it for a multitude of reasons
like a say I was on the date where we're
bungee jumping gay kid
I would I would leave I you they can't
force you to do that but then it's like
what's the date bungee jumping
that's insane enough that's insane I
don't know but it's honest I really
commend like if you think about I really
commend the people who go on the show it
is so scary ever like from start to
finish it's a scary thing 100% but
that's why they get so much from going
on the show
there it's so rewarding if you know you
make it far and like then your followers
and brand Nielsen whatever so it's like
the risk is worth the reward for a lot
of people for some people it's like it's
the biggest was there alive yeah
they're roasted alive and they just can
never get past it yeah I agree
um I want to talk about Real Housewives
of New York quickly because it was the
finale episode really the reunion looks
to be interesting one because that's
when LuAnn has relapsed they look like
they're really starting to go in on
Tinsley where now I'm seeing how maybe
that page six article what didn't come
out of nowhere because it looks like
they're accusing her of just not living
in New York and like having a fake life
like she lives in a hotel on the show so
she probably that just doesn't live here
during the rest of the year and why are
you on Real Housewives of New York if
you don't live in New York
okay she's trying to say like that's not
a big deal but it like it's just this
isn't a big show there are enough
interesting women in New York like if
you don't live here don't be on the show
yeah I do really like her though so I
hope it works out for her but she just
needs to like nut up um LuAnn did her
cabaret fun times I really don't even
know what I was having Bethenny like had
a near-death experience with an allergy
oh we're I'm really sad and I feel as
though I remember when we talked about
it on the show because it was a news
story that she has this really bad fish
allergy there was one story where she
was on a plane and something happened
and there was something else this was
something else where she was just in
Boston and she had to go to the ER and I
remember thinking at the time like when
celebrities have these allergy things
more often than not it's like a cover-up
or something I like canceled tour
because you know my allergies and it
really takes away from like people with
very severe serious allergies and I felt
really badly for her because it was
obviously such a scary experience and
I'm sure whenever we report on it like
we didn't take it serious and I'm sure a
lot of people didn't take it seriously
and when you say with allergies you just
assume like you're covering up or
something so whatever I did say I'm just
like you take about whatever it was I'm
I take it back
and I just I she's just had such a rough
year like I just my heart was like
breaking for her but it seems like she's
in a really good place right now like
she's a man they bought a townhouse
together in Boston Wow
he was photographed like in Boston is
she gonna leave I don't think she'll
leave New York but Boston and New York
are close enough
like you can do both it's gonna cost in
on Tuesday in like some ways it's easier
to get to Boston than it is to get to
the Hamptons 100% so I think it'll be
okay
you know yeah oh yes um I just wanted to
catch up with you because you have
recently moved into your apartment
I heard you're a purple mattress how's
it going it's so comfortable look I
didn't even need to get anything to put
on top of it have you been having the
best sleep of your life yeah
it's Theo gonna love it when he sleeps
with you I hope so I think he will
because if you're struggling to get a
good night's sleep you gotta try a
purple mattress that's what he needed
last night purple mattress the founders
of purple are two brothers who have been
developing cushioning technology for 30
years on things like medical beds and
wheelchairs so words of sisters who
support other siblings in 2016 they
finally decided to use their patented
comfort technology to create purple the
world's most scientific mattress the
purple mattress will probably feel
different than anything you've ever
experienced because it uses this
brand-new material that was developed by
an actual rocket scientist this is a
NASA it was not like the memory foam
that we're used to the purple material
feels very unique because it's both firm
and soft at the same time get you a
mattress that can do both so it keeps
everything supported while still feeling
really comfortable plus it's breathable
so it sleeps cool so if you want to try
your free in-home setup and get your old
mattress removed they'll bring in a
purple mattress and it's gonna be the
best sleep of your life you're going to
love purple and right now our listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text toast to
eight four eight eight eight that the
only way to get this free pillow is to
text toast to eight four eight eight
eight that's tio ast two eight four
eight eight eight message and data rates
may apply we get the best sleep of your
life guys you deserve it you know really
life is hard
life is hard and sleep makes it all
better
that's true watch Evans live tenth
anniversary episode I just wanted to
touch on because I thought it was gonna
be like a whole thing you know like a
live show almost kind of like when they
do watch Evans live in LA where there's
like a huge audience and it's like a
spectacular but it was just a one-on-one
with Chrissy Teigen yeah which was weird
I thought you know I was actually just
saying to Claudia the other day like I
used to like Christian
like release to bother mean like she is
like slowly but surely like been winning
me over
me today kind of like stand her now I
stand her to and she was fine last night
like she's she's great and I love how
much she loves Bravo um but it's just
not what I thought for the 10th
anniversary like that and I thought it
was gonna be a trio of Chrissie John
Mayer and Lynne which they all came on
at various points but it wasn't three of
them sitting there was like a one-on-one
with Chrissy Teigen and I just didn't
understand that choice I would have
preferred a one-on-one with Andy in the
guest chair and someone interviewing him
about the past ten years yeah even if it
was John Mayer or Anderson Cooper who's
like such a hose yeah it would have been
awesome Kelly Ripa that yeah she he's
friends with all the great best hopes
yes one of the Ginny's like one of the
Jimmy's and love Jimmy Fallon I wanted
to hear from Andy like about the past
ten years yet not Chrissy Teigan on her
thoughts on all the different Housewives
and she's so friendly with all of the
different Bravo cast members that she
wouldn't say anything she needs she
might even be in Kentucky didn't even
answer any of the questions she was like
he would say what are your thoughts on
this beef and she would recap the beef
and then not say yeah yeah you know yeah
yeah I feel that know that she was like
what are your who sat on LBP or everyone
else and she was like isn't this the
best press for Radar Online like but
whose side are you on yeah LVP or
everyone else she was like I think any
of them would be Kasturi to Radar Online
and I'm like but whose side are you on
LVP where everyone else that what you
did yeah I was watching with you and he
was [ __ ] up in arms he was like what
are you dodging yeah you can dodge a
wrench you can dodge Andy's question and
she did you can dodge a ball anyways
it's Friday so thank you all for bearing
with us this week next week we have a
short week because it is a holiday
holiday and our intern is going to
Massachusetts yeah Roxanna chooses cool
fun so we'll be back Monday Tuesday
cloudy and I Monday we have such a
special episode because we have some of
the women from New York one joining us
who are involved in the case against New
York one and discrimination against
women and ageism and we will have Roma
Tory
Wow um jazz which is just if you're into
workers or if you've ever watched New
York one like you know that this is
two huge Hill and it's really exciting
for us because I like New York one is
just such a part of the city yeah so
it's really exciting so Monday will be
great we'll be back on Tuesday we're
gonna have a great weekend we're gonna
see huge Ackman tonight yes we are gonna
try it on Sunday and we have pride on
Sunday and it's an NW oh yeah Wow what
so many things so forward to so many
being excited for Green Week in New York
because pride is kicking off today and
it's just gonna be a wonderful
celebration of love and I can't wait to
all of my outfits came from forever 21
I'm very excited for them do you have
like anything extra because I was a pair
of shorts that like they're white and
have a rainbow on the sides are really
Cupid they were ginormous on me which
means they're not to that you that's
really nice of you to say I had
something in mind but I'm just worried
it's gonna be too hot
yeah I'll show you what I'm wearing
because um it's the shorts I'm wearing
or a teeny tiny tiny tiny they're so
small like you got movement thank you
for joining us here in turn with the
mostest okay I've upgraded I'm sorry
it's taking I'm just like getting used
to it you're the PA with the mostest and
today you're the hostess with the
mostess oh yeah so where can everyone
follow you in your new youtube channel
YouTube channel TBD I'm at Margaux you
know what's get me 200k man oh my god
yes you're so influential you have to be
at answer I'm at 86 and fellow a pup
with no job because he's posting premium
content all weekend now that he's at his
aunt's house and like my house is really
not just his vibe like yes general
aesthetics so he always likes to post a
lot of pictures for my place did you see
what he posted this morning oh my god
he's just so like what's the word um
learn it learn it
he's so learned it he was reading the
paper and he was actually sharing with
me some of the stories that he thought
would make for good topics on the show
dude oh so the quorum was definitely him
of course he loves corn yeah who doesn't
and I love to try everybody's corn but
only the best one survive if you've
never seen that that end video you have
not bad that video this is a binder that
does it I no idea how do you knows
people will know if I wait long enough
his name I think his name is Chris oh oh
I don't know I don't know let's say
justice for him I'm gonna wait can
someone remind us who makes that and I'd
love to try everybody's corn but only
the best
oh [ __ ] epic no one knows no one's
answering yet okay he's just given a
minute because it's delayed and in the
meantime you can always follow me I
track your problems if you're doing
something fun this weekend you're taking
premium content you might want to
download that Jackie O flo-jo yeah we'll
be holding on Jackie O four I want all
of our picks this weekend oh yeah folks
show just like it's the summer vibe it
really is a summer vibe some of ABS dice
okay we're not thinking through me
nobody's saying it will find the video
and we'll post it later we love you all
have a great weekend bye
you